[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in a
world rich with magic one of the most
captivating aspects is the existence of
the Deathly Hallows fabled magical
artifacts that go back many centuries
these legendary artifacts consisting of
the Elder one the resurrection Stone and
the visibility cloak hold immense power
and significance and according to
Wizarding folklore anyone who possesses
all three Hallows attains the esteemed
title of a master of death today we'll
be diving deep into the tale of the
Three Brothers taking a closer look at
the history of these artifacts as well
as what it actually means to be a master
of death but before we get started no
discussion surrounding the Deathly
Hallows is complete without a summary of
where these artifacts came from The Tale
of Three Brothers once upon a time in a
world of magic and mystery there lived
Three Brothers they were known as the
peveril brothers and they possessed
extraordinary skills and knowledge of
ancient magic one day while traveling
along a treacherous road the brothers
found themselves facing a treacherous
River using their ones they conjured a
bridge to cross the river and safely
reach the other side
however as they stepped onto the bridge
they were met by a figure standing in
their path it was death itself Furious
that they had cheated their way across
its River however death under the guise
of congratulating them offered each of
the three Wizards a reward of their
choosing the oldest brother Antioch
asked for a wand more powerful than any
other one that would make him the
unbeatable master of dueling obliging
death crafted the Elder Wand and handed
it to Antioch the second brother Cadmus
baded with death to bring back his
beloved who had perished death handed
him the resurrection Stone claiming that
it could summon the spirits of the Dead
eagerly taking the stone Cadmus believed
he had cheated death and could bring his
loved one back to life the youngest
brother ignotus unlike his brothers was
wise and humble rather than seeking
power or Resurrection he wish to evade
death in response death gave him a cloak
of exceptional quality an invisibility
cloak that would Shield him from death's
sight the cloak was unique for it had
the power to conceal the wearer
indefinitely making them truly
invisible after this trial The Three
Brothers went their separate ways each
in possession of their respective
Hallows antiok used the Elder one to
become a feared and powerful wizard
relishing his dominance over others
however his lust for power led to his
downfall as a thief eventually murdered
him in his sleep to steal the wand
Cadmus filled with grief and Desperation
used the resurrection Stone to bring
back his lost love yet he soon realized
that the figure who returned was nothing
but an echo an incomplete shadow of his
beloved consumed by sorrow and unable to
move on Cadmus took his own life unable
to live without the true presence of his
love as for a notice he lived a long and
content life protected by his
invisibility cloak recognizing the cloak
significance he passed it down through
generations ensuring that its power
remained hidden and protected the tale
of the three brothers passed down
through the ages became a legend
symbolizing the interconnectedness of
power resurrection and the evasiveness
of death these Deathly Hallows showcase
the Frailty of human desires and the
consequences that come with tampering
with the natural order it served as a
reminder that in the end death comes for
all the master of death unsurprisingly
the popular tale surrounding the three
wizard Brothers sparked considerable
discussion in the Widing World though
the story is very ancient and widely
believed to be a fairy tale of sorts
certain Concepts were able to gain
traction like the myth behind there
being a master of death attacking line
that's thrown around quite a bit in
Harry Potter without much proper
explanation that is a children's tale
told to amuse rather than to instruct
those of us who understand these matters
however recognize that the ancient story
refers to three objects or Hallows which
if United will make the possessor master
of death the concept of being a master
of death is directly tied to possessing
all three Deathly Hallows the idea is
that the person who will wields all
three Hallows would become the true
master and conqueror of death able to
wield all three immensely powerful
magical objects at once but what does
that actually mean sure it sounds cool
but what does it do for you are you
immortal do you have the power to
control the spirits of others do you
become the physical manifestation of
death mentioned in the tale of the
Deathly Hallows can you snap your
fingers and end lives save them or is
this more of a vanity title lacking any
sort of considerable depth at one time
two of the most formidable Wizards in
The Wizarding World G grindal and alus
Dumbledore were consumed by an
overwhelming fascination with this
concept so surely there must be
something to it right the first thing to
note is that being a master of death
represents different aspects of
mortality and its relationship with
power resurrection and
invisibility the Elder Wand signifies
the power over others the resurrection
stone represents the longing for life
after death and the invisibility cloak
symbolizes the ability to evade the
inevitability of death together these
Hallows create a Triad that encompasses
the different facets of Humanity's
relationship with
mortality when attempting to understand
the concept of being a master of death
some may immediately think of Harry
Potter as an Exemplar considering that
he seemed to possess all three deathly
Halls at one point for example before
venturing into the Forbidden Forest to
face Voldemort Harry was covered by the
invisibility cloak held the resurrection
Stone in his grasp and was regarded as
the Elder one's loyal owner by
extension however it's worth noting that
despite his claim of loyalty of the
Elder ones Harry never physically
possessed it at the time he carried the
other two Hallows as a result it can be
argued that he never truly achieved
these St status of a master of death and
by the time Harry did hold the Elder
Wand in his hands he had already dropped
the resurrection Stone somewhere in the
Forbidden Forest even though Harry was
probably far closer than anyone else in
history to possess all three he didn't
quite hit the mark with that said
Harry's failure was pretty much only
down to the fact that he didn't care
Dumbledore explains the Hallows to Harry
later in the story maybe a man in a
million could unite the Hallows Harry
I'm was fit only to possess the meanest
of them the least extraordinary I was
fit to own the Elder ones and not to
boast of it and not to kill with it I
was permitted to tame and to use it
because I took it not for gain but to
save others from it but the cloak I took
out of vain curiosity and so it could
never have worked for me as it works for
you it's true owna the stone I would
have used in an attempt to drag back
those who are at peace rather than to
enable myself sacrifice as you did you
are the worthy possessor of the Hallows
Dumbledore patted Harry's hand and Harry
looked up at the old man and smiled he
could not help himself how could he
remain angry with Dumbledore now why did
you have to make it so difficult
Dumbledore's smile was tremulous I'm
afraid I counted on Miss Granger to slow
you up Harry I was afraid that your hot
head might dominate your good heart I
was scared that if presented outright
with the facts about those tempting
objects you might cease the Hallows as I
did at the wrong time for the wrong
reasons if you laid hands on them I
wanted you to possess them safely while
it is generally assumed that becoming
the master of death refers to some form
of immortality here Dumbledore reveals
the still rather ambiguous information
that the true master of death is one who
is able to truly accept the fact that
death is inevitable and that there are
other things worse than dying you are
the true master of death because the
true Master does not seek to run away
from Death he accepts that he must die
and understands that there are far far
worse things in the living world than
dying basically it means nothing though
the implications have becoming a master
of death are not definitively explained
all pointers seem to suggest that it
Bears no actual significance at most May
indicate that the person has overcome
their fear of death and has found peace
with its inevitability
personally I lean towards this
interpretation as well as the notion
that the Deathly Hallows are simply
powerful artifacts created by the peral
brothers rather than the TR gifts
bestowed by death however in fan created
content the concept of being a master of
death often takes on varying
interpretations it can range from
Notions of immortality to being equated
with being death itself or even
transcending the power of death the the
problem here is that from a narrative
standpoint presenting the master of
death as Immortal contradicts the core
message that JK Rowling consistently
aimed to convey throughout the story she
repeatedly emphasized that death should
not be feared but rather accepted as an
inevitable part of life when the time
arrives the portrayal of immortality
would not only validate Voldemort's
misguided beliefs but also undermine the
Thematic exploration of the series and
that's it for the this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to
live